頂尖的 AI 研究者跟諾蘭說
現在是他們的奧本海默時刻
諾蘭很高興他們回頭看歷史
只是這個故事他研究了這麼久
不確定裡面有具體的答案可以學
這段對談是科學節 Starmus 今年 9 月初公開的
場合是頒給他霍金科學傳播獎章
他是 2024 年的得主
跟他對談的 Kip Thorne 拿過諾貝爾物理學獎
也是《星際效應》的科學顧問
第一個問題由他來問，問的是核武
這件事我放在心裡很久，昨晚還在想
我想起 1950、60 年代，
當時我自己、我的物理學家同事，
政治人物，還有一般大眾，
都深深擔心核子浩劫
那個年代我常待在蘇聯，
那邊的憂慮跟這裡一樣深，甚至更深
我認為那是一股穩定的力量，保護我們不至於…
你在電影裡形容這是瓶子裡的兩隻蠍子，
美國跟蘇聯
世界變了，
現在這一代人，大多渾然不覺有這個危險
你的電影《奧本海默》喚起了很多人的注意，
我很高興看到有社論跟評論因為你的電影而寫出來
你拍《奧本海默》，喚起大家注意是你的目標之一嗎？
你自己又怎麼看這件事，
畢竟你花了這麼多時間思考奧本海默、拍這部片
大致上，我會投入一個案子，都是為了故事
就是戲劇性、敘事上有沒有意思
但《奧本海默》這一部，
我第一次跟我一個兒子說我在做什麼，他那時候大概 16 歲，
他居然跟我說：核武那些，
現在沒什麼人在擔心了吧
這句話讓我非常震驚
我心想，光是這樣，就是拍這部片的理由
兒子那句話還給了他一個提醒
觀眾走進戲院的時候
心裡不一定還惦記著核武
電影得自己把那份威脅演出來
拍完之後，我非常擔心的就是你講的這件事
因為不管你是主張核武應該從世界上徹底消失，
也不管你覺得那做不做得到，
還是像有些人那樣，看到歐洲比起一戰二戰相對和平，
就說是相互保證毀滅的威脅維持了一些和平
事實是，相互保證毀滅這個概念要有用，
前提是人對核武的毀滅力，有足夠的恐懼跟敬畏
所以不管你怎麼看核威脅…
我個人認為，地球上的核武越少越好，就這樣
這是最簡單的看法
但不管你怎麼看，就算你接受相互保證毀滅這套想法，
它要有用，我們就得一直擔心、一直去想，
一直對各國領袖施壓，要他們減少核武，
也要對那種毀滅力保有該有的敬畏，
那是獨一無二的威脅
電影上映的時候，我讀到一兩篇比較圈內的批評，
是這個領域的人寫的，
他們說電影是用絕望收尾，這樣講沒有錯
我覺得在戲劇上那是必要的，
要讓觀眾感受到真實的威脅，這很重要
他也承認這樣收尾有代價
觀眾可能因此看不到 1945 年以來削減核彈頭的成果
他說人對核武的恐懼一直跟著國際情勢起伏
電影開拍那時候俄烏局勢惡化
大家才又談起來，他認為不該這樣
接著發問的是 Starmus 的共同創辦人 Garik Israelian
科技可以救我們，也可以毀了我們
科技可以幫我們擋下氣候變遷跟很多事，但它也可以毀了我們
所以大家說，一切都掌握在我們手上
但什麼能改變我們？
我們得被改變才行
我認為科學史上一直有一種掙扎，
社會跟人性要怎麼消化科學發現
原子彈誕生的時候，這件事暴露得最徹底，也最嚇人
但我覺得這個問題一直都在
知識帶來責任
隨著知識而來的是，知識很有用，同時也可能很危險
它帶來力量，也帶來責任，你得決定新科技要怎麼用
過去這一年，尤其是最近六個月，
我花很多時間跟人談，奧本海默的故事跟 AI 現在的處境有什麼關係
嗯
讓我覺得振奮的是，我跟 AI 領域的頂尖研究者聊過，
他們說這是他們的「奧本海默時刻」，
因為對我來說，這代表他們在回頭看過去
他們在歷史裡找例子，特別把奧本海默的故事當成警世故事
他們在問：我們能從這裡學到什麼？
我研究奧本海默的故事研究了這麼久，
我不確定裡面有具體的答案可以學
問題就在這裡
這個故事拍成戲會好看，就是因為它充滿矛盾，
滿滿都是沒有簡單答案的問題
但至少我很高興他們有在想、有在看，
會說：我們真的要記得，新科技
再怎麼讓人興奮、再怎麼誘人，都可能帶來可怕的意外後果
我覺得現在談 AI，這件事被擺在最前面，這是好事
Kip Thorne 接著提到電影裡的一場戲
原子彈投下之後
奧本海默進白宮見杜魯門總統
說他覺得自己手上沾了血
電影裡你拍杜魯門總統怎麼回應奧本海默的憂慮，那段讓我印象很深
他基本上是罵奧本海默愛哭鬼，
然後用他在別處講過的話宣告：責任到我為止
該煩惱的人是我，不關你的事
炸彈是你做的，但責任在我
但這就帶出一個問題，到了那種層級，
科學家要負多少責任？
創造的人應該負責，但他們要怎麼負？
政治跟科學之間的互動，真的變得很複雜
奧本海默的故事，我越想，
拍完片、放給觀眾看、像這樣跟人談，
我就越明白，他走出杜魯門辦公室的那一刻，
為什麼我一直覺得它那麼關鍵，以前卻說不上來，
是因為它代表科學跟政治的關係破裂了，
科學跟當權者的關係破裂了
這對科學傳播是很大的問題，對 AI 也是
它帶來的後果，你在氣候變遷的所有討論裡都看得到，
還有科學家為了那場辯論，在媒體上怎麼拉扯
因為科學跟政治當權者之間，如果沒有健康、單純的關係，
科學就只能去找媒體，靠媒體居中傳話
這一定會把科學講淺
這是個問題，因為當科學家不得不…
當他們被逼到得把自己的研究講淺，才能讓大家注意某件事，
他們就失去公信力，
因為很容易被挑出破綻
氣候變遷就是這樣，
有些比較聳動、比較戲劇化的說法，很容易被挑出破綻，
因為那樣講，科學上就不是無懈可擊
要把真實情況講出來比較複雜，這得在政治的層次上做
你需要專家小組、需要科學家的團體，
向政府說明真正的科學是什麼、該做什麼
不能全部透過媒體
而我認為，奧本海默的故事就是這種情況開始的關鍵時刻之一，
三腳架突然多了第三隻腳
曼哈頓計畫是祕密進行的，
政府跟科學的關係，可以說有效率得可怕，
突然之間，它被攤開到第三個場域，也就是大眾的目光、媒體
這就扭曲了政治人物跟科學家的關係，
我覺得我們到現在都還在承受後果
這是非常複雜的問題
我想真正的解法，或者說目標，
是讓最懂的人跟制定政策的人，有一個最健康的關係，
也許不要老是在大眾面前上演，
讓它成為有成果的專家對話
但這得靠大眾的壓力，所以…
沒錯
所以我們得把科學傳達給一般大眾
對
再由大眾去對政治人物施壓：各位，聽科學家的
對，而難就難在，怎麼做到這件事，又保住科學的精細
後來 Garik 問他
太空競賽激勵過一整代人
下一個會是什麼
諾蘭先講了重返太空跟火星
所以我很喜歡往宇宙更遠的地方看
比起地球上跟電腦有關的那些科技突破，我個人對這個更有興趣
更能點燃我想像力的是探索，是那些遙遠的距離跟可能的發現
不過這每個人不一樣
我覺得有很多事，比如在 AI 這個領域，
我們一直在看它的危險、看它被濫用，
但它實際的用途，還有年輕人能拿這項技術做什麼，
像是做影像，像是變出新的故事、新的手法、新的方式來表達自己，
這會在未來幾十年，真正點燃年輕人的想像力
一定會
AI 研究者想從奧本海默的故事裡找答案
諾蘭不確定裡面有現成的
他看到的是科學跟政治從那時候起就斷了線
不過他沒有因此看壞 AI
他認為年輕人會拿它說出新的故事
原影片 21 分鐘，他最後還講到
科學現在被當成政治足球在踢
他認為解法是教育
因為在人類想出來的所有哲學裡
只有科學會設法推翻自己
開頭 Kip Thorne 還講了霍金看完《星際效應》有多興奮
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。